violence notorious for the number of
ships and planes that have gone missing
the 1954 nuclear test water test they
were trying to kill something that's
called King around here
it's time to kill that man is king
rush
Islands rated pg-13 experience at an
IMAX much end these are photos of an
island in the South Pacific the place
where myths of science me we use
explicit to shake the earth helping us
to map the surface of the island gives
off and wrong side to forget you
Wow
magnificent you need that thing without
here I'm sorry for your mentor but if
you want to make your sacrifice
worthwhile get us home
with proof monsters exist
your friend there can put that down
what the hell is this place
that's call your King around here sounds
pretty good king
he still self mostly where you don't go
into someone house and start dropping
bombs
unless you're picking a fight going God
on the island but the Devils live below
it and what if a cool
homes go crawlers why never said that
name out loud before it sounds stupid
now that I say just you call them
whatever you want
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here ha ha this
is the coming
you